my name is David Osby and I'm the chief
science officer for savant x i also have
27 x employees here at hein buckle here
CEO and jacob grimm I think he's here
semi so the title today is the
computable human is kind of an
intriguing title so let's jump right
into it so Sivan axe is a totally
Mathematica version 10 written
application and for today i think i'm
going to use the working definition of
sivan x being a generalized relationship
analysis system today I'm going to
basically start with a big picture and
then narrow down going to take a slice
out of Sonic's because there's actually
quite a bit to talk about we usually do
this in an hour and when they have 20
minutes today so as a brief history I
could go into a Ned was going to give
that but we exit amount and interest of
time but basically sivan x was its
predecessor was a protocol just a pro
and it ran and cloud under Nimbus
systems or nemeth services and and then
we did a bunch of government work with
that tool what's called OSN tore open
source intelligence and then that
eventually became savant x okay our
first client first upon X is looks like
this it's a power plant a large power
plant has 1,500 workers 24-7 as you can
imagine providing electricity for
million homes lots of different job
functions that you can imagine financial
legal accounting lots of information
workers so I have them represent my
desks down there
client issues
I can't find anything I wish I could
predict XYZ whatever how do we fix this
last time why did this happen what's the
relationship between X and Y how would
Harold have solved this and then Harold
retired but the truth is out there is
that in the next three years are going
to be losing eighty percent of their it
workforce to retirement so there's a big
knowledge strain going on okay to solve
some of those problems what do we have
access to one of the data sources we
have is sensors the plant has got
hundreds of sensors all over temperature
gauges and pressure gauges things like
that and sensors are great because they
have these characteristics here you can
see my little thing here homewood genius
outputs perhaps the most important thing
in other words if you take the
temperature gauge it's always going to
read temperatures not going to decide to
read pressure or something like that it
has a known accuracy generally it has
known reliability it works twenty-four
seven kinda like Jacob does has
continuous output you can relocate the
output somewhere so you can have a
sensor in one place then you can
relocate the output to another place it
can endure in dangerous environments and
does he know it does have a fixed
location the thing is you have a little
sensors but how do they really help you
with the problem set that you have
really not that much to help you find
anything no not really doesn't really
predict anything he might a little bit
perhaps but not much so go down through
this list you think how did these
sensors help now there is it's true that
there is a segment of the plant that's
really interested in in those gauges and
certainly the control room is but that's
a very small part of the plant really
so doesn't really help that much we have
another huge data source though and that
is the human generated data there are
1500 people as I said and quite a few
more information workers they're
producing about thousand pages of stuff
per day generally in the form of text
some of its structured the most of its
text goes into databases in this case
they have 35 databases 50 million pages
over time has accumulated almost all of
its scanned because they got in the
habit of taking PDFs of documents which
then would turn into scan documents and
then filing it away in a document
storage system and so there was sit it's
not really searchable
so what if we could what if we had a way
of taking that text that's being
generated and considering human beings
as sensors of types it sounds kind of
like a crazy idea the top of the list
there it's you know you don't get
homogeneous output from human there
uncalibrated unknown reliability look
there's slowed output can't really
report from a dangerous location and the
output in a strange thing called human
language it's not really non-computer
comprehensible code but on the other
hand humans are mobile they can go
anywhere in the plant in fact they do
they're swarming all over the plant
their observant they're smart they can
detect anomalies that a sensor probably
never could do they're already in place
there's lots of them out there and they
have existing recording protocols but if
we were to consider human beings as
sensors what are they trying to tell us
so we need to figure that out if we're
going to consider them as sensors so if
you look through our problems that we
had and kind of categorize the type of
problem that it is you come up with
three general things what we call search
discover and analyze so sometimes you
say savant X is a search discovered
analyzed tool and you can see how they
divide up here into this set the first
one of course is the one that brought us
to the plant originally was they said
well we just can't find what we're
looking for and it goes on from there
hmmm prediction is of course an analysis
task and then how do we fix this last
time a search to discover task and so on
so the first thing that savant has to do
is it wants to build a single place that
everybody can go to get the answers to
the questions they have why do we do
that right now if you have a problem at
the plant yet to figure out which of the
35 places might the answer be and then
you have to go and run a specialized
search tool or something within that
database to find the problem find what
you're looking for so it's savant we
have the same you know savants never met
data it didn't like so we have the
ability to take pretty much any kind of
file and turn it into text that's
eventually turned into indexes and then
of course a source document itself is
retained in there I'm going to skip by
this we don't have time so now I'm going
to go down into one particular aspect of
savant namely search and show you the
kind of thinking that went into building
savant and I'll go through these tabs
and kind of describe how we do it and
you can apply that kind of thinking
throughout savant okay so when we look
at a search task with the user they have
this vague idea there's this bubble of
stuff out there and they might be trying
to do a search for say a valve failure
and so they have this idea I want this
stuff to come out it's represented by
that bubble there the thing is that this
is really what they're getting and
that's primarily because almost all of
these apps are using key term SQL kinds
of queries to find the answers we're
going to describe to you why that bottom
shape there is the shape it is first
thing that happens is that you have all
the scanned stuff going on if you don't
turn the scan stuff in the text there's
no way you can search against it and so
that that vertical line here
right here is due to that aspect second
thing is we have what we call stemming
you really want to not only look for the
word Val but you want to work for the
word valve or valves and when you do
that you gain a little bit of some
returns that you would not otherwise how
there is quite a bit of overlap overlap
but not totally and failure is even more
interesting this is actually taken from
some of their data reduced down so the
proportions are probably correct so
failure is pretty good word but if you
use the word fail you would have only
have gotten this but by doing stemming
or the roots of failure you find all of
this information here like that so it
increases your return set so I stemming
you basically can doing some boolean
type logic on on that you'll get that
long list of possible variations on the
search terms that the user typed in I
don't know if you can read those are
pretty small maybe I can make this a
little bigger here see what I can do
this let me do it easily
there we go let's try that okay so
that's gotten us to where we have all
these returns now but the problem now is
that you have a lot of stuff and I'd say
about generally about half of its
useless now why is that one of the
reasons is that at the plant they have a
lot of documents that are hundreds of
pages thousands of pages of in fact
we've seen a couple that are over 10,000
pages long and that means that basically
those documents have every possible term
in the plant in them so pretty much no
matter which kind of search terms you
type in your going to get those
documents returned to you it's not very
useful so we really want to find out
context now context the traditional kind
of weapon of choice has been LSA latent
semantic analysis and that's a technique
that was invented by bell labs back in
the 60s it's pretty interesting
mathematically speaking what they would
do is they would take a passage of some
text say like this and then they would
that would go across the top and then
down the left-hand side they'd put the
vocabulary found in that passage and
they'd put the number of hits they would
get that passage in this matrix so that
matrix gets very large as you can
imagine if you have millions of
documents you're going to generate
probably hundreds of thousands of terms
down the left-hand side and it's a
sparse or a it's mostly filled with
zeros but then if you do a singular
value decomposition on it you can turn
that array into three arrays such when
you multiply them together you get the
original matrix back and the center
array is the singular values and these
the left hand side and right hand side
or right angles to each other then that
effect of it is that you can then
squeeze the arrays can squeeze the the
noise out of it squeeze it way down and
turns out through a pretty interesting
trick you actually get meaning from
you can actually extract meaning from
passages the problem is with LSA is it
requires a supercomputer to decompose
these arrays and then when you add yet
another passage is when we're passage
you get to do the whole decomposition
again because to find out how that
passage relates to the other passages
you have to take the vector and reduce
it down and it's a big job have a little
example here of how LSA would work
against a photograph the decomposed a
photograph so have a photograph here
this 200 512 pixels by 512 pixels square
and I've now reduced it down the
singular value decomposition under one
dimension and this is what the picture
would look like and as you add
dimensions back in you'll start to see
something we're at three dimensions
probably some of you know what this is
already so we get the five six seven
eight start to see a face and so on so
out of those 512 dimensions at say
between eight and 12 dimensions you're
going to start to see concepts of source
now so that's how LSA works but if you
don't have a supercomputer you can't do
that so in our client certainly doesn't
have one of those the only people that
really do that kind of work as maybe
some basic work at Google they might do
some pure research there and a
government's done some work with us too
but certainly not your average company
so we had to come up with a different
way of computing context and meaning at
visual at the savant so we did is I'd
done some work with previously with
networks and which is based on graph
theory and so I decided to
look at text let's say we have some text
down the left-hand column here and then
form relationships between them as other
nodes and graphs looks like this I drove
my car into work today I can make these
relationships between drove and car and
car and work and working today I paid
insurance on my car today and so on so
you get these relationships so you might
say this is the 1d version of that right
here we look at that in 2d with graphing
theory you get this obviously car is a
central theme of that set of text and
then you have these relationships here
going out and we can look at it in three
dimensions like this all pretty standard
mathematical stuff I have another set of
texts let's say it's about an airplane I
always wanted to fly out to learn how to
fly an airplane you get these this
relationship here I fly my airplane to
work every week you get these sets of
relationships and so on if you look at
that in two dimensions you get this as
you would expect if you look at in three
dimensions you see it this way but what
happens when you combine both of them
together if you look at it in one
dimension you see this it's not actually
very difficult right Lu you look at it
in two dimensions it looks like this
this is a little more interesting first
of all you see that airplane and car are
centrally located they have no direct
relationship to each other but you have
all these things that they share around
the periphery if you look at in three
dimensions it's pretty interesting
notice that no matter where I twist this
car and airplane are never far from each
other the reason for that is pretty much
the same reason why LS a works which is
when words share relationships they form
a context with each other and so even
although you were used different terms
if they're if they're sharing other
words they probably share a meaning in
this case it's transportation and so I
can twist this around notice that the
words that are in the periphery
are less related in the ones that your
clothes are in and for instance drove
and flyer up by themselves because
that's one of the ways are
differentiated from each other okay so
now how about a real-world example
unfortunately I can't really show you
the terms that are involved in this but
this is the word ladder looking at some
plant data and doing that same kind of
computation you'll see the word ladder
is actually centrally located here
they're not labeled but it's in the
center these dots were out here are
these nose out here are other words
which are less related and then more
centrally located terms are more related
to the word library so we can look at
that in three dimensions like this and
you'll see some very nice clumping
that's going on it's kind of like words
make a social network of sorts and some
words like to hang out together more
than other words and so you get this
clustering effect and so as you increase
the dimensionality of your analysis
you'll get better and better clustering
the thing is after dimension 3 the human
wine can't understand it there's nobody
to press to display above three
dimensions but savant can actually think
up in two you know five six seven eight
dimensions not unlike what we saw that
mathematical intuition on the LSA graph
that I showed you the photograph there
so when you type a word say ladder
accident into savant it actually thinks
about ladder this way and it thinks
about accent you know something like
this and then it looks at the
relationships and can tell which
concepts are centrally located to those
and then do an index into those
documents that have that feature okay I
gotta go quick here kind of run out of
time on so let's go back to our original
problem here here's what they wanted and
here's what they got and as I'm going to
explain your rapidly how we
how Sivan actually gets this correct
bubble first of all it gets this half of
this bubble here because we actually
turn the scan text and scan images into
text with OCR these here this little
segment here that we don't want is
eliminated by our LS a replacement of
graph theory this section in here is
handled by stems and this piece up here
is from some savante I that we don't
have time to talk about today